hello today we are going to talk about
normalizing the table of expression
rna scene data has been shown to have
skewed distributions on equal variances
and extreme values
most statistical tests including ones
that we use in our analysis have an
assumption of normality the three
aforementioned issues violate these
assumptions
there are a number of normalization
approaches that may be used a standard
approach includes conversion of values
to log scale and adjusting the
distribution to account for technical
variability of low expressed genes
aligning the mean of distribution
between all samples in a set
on the t bioinfo platform both of these
can be done using the quantile
normalization utility
this utility can be found on the main
areas of analysis page
quantile normalization and other
normalization procedures are important
to transform distributions both between
and amongst different samples to have
the same distribution
this removes unwanted technical
variation that could cause perceived
differences between samples when there
are in fact no differences in terms of
the biology
quantile normalization is a technique of
mapping original values the
corresponding quantile of a standard
distribution
here an estimation of the sequencing
depth of an experiment is determined by
an upper quartile of his counts
comparing quantile values instead of raw
values will eliminate differences solely
rooted in the in the technical variation
such as the amount of rna sequenced
sequencing machine type or even
unexplained differences that arise
between different technicians following
the same protocol in addition while
normalizing data we will use a log
transformation that makes it easier to
interpret differences in gene expression
to use both normalization and log normal
transformation of the expression data
select quantile normalization
after start
and
set the following settings
the transform table to ln should be s
and threshold should be 5.
now we are ready to download the table
output and compare expression between
fbkm and normalized data
a good way to compare normalized and
adjusted data is to take a few samples
and visualize all gene expression
numbers as a box plot
this method of data visualization
popular to summarize data shows the
maximum minimum and mean values for each
sample
while displaying the interquartile
ranges of upper and lower interquartile
ranges thus we can see some detail but
not too much to lose the trend
you can prepare the box plots in excel
to see how it can show us a comparison
between fbk output and normalized data
the first figure shows the majority of
values that is not seen at all because
there is a gap between the majority low
levels and some outlier high values in
the selected samples
after normalization this gap disappears
placing most of the data into a more
easily distinguishable scale
in fact it shows the variance of data
that is needed for a comprehensive
comparison for example if we prepare a
box plot of all the samples we will see
that some of them are outliers
the outlier status of the sample is not
by level of expression of any single
gene
it shows that the variance of this data
set is different from the others the
mean of the sample is just a little
higher than the rest but the distance
between the mean value of the lower
interquartile range and the maximum of
the top interquartile range is much
bigger than the rest of the samples
to learn more about normalization you
can visit lesson number 12 under
transcriptomics on learn.omicslogic.com
portal